how do you like working with Jack do you
like working with I love working with
Jack McBrayer look at this man this man
is a pro you know he's a two-time Emmy
loser he was nominated twice Wow for an
Emmy for the great 30 rock and he lost
okay it's okay Jack your luck is about
to change because this show is never
getting nominated for it we get along
well though don't we Jack yes I think we
do I think you know what it helps Conan
it helps that we're not attracted to the
same type of women or even species I
like a sexy border collie and
Jacqueline's more towards various
livestock all right listen
listen you're the one who invented the
Jack McBrayer job they don't know that
that's the important breathing your
rejects now I understand that you've
been trying to work with Jack for years
triumph oh yeah yours to have a project
with the great Jack McBrayer yes that's
true yes here it comes we're going to
cut the funny pictures well we've had
many shows together right we tried many
pilots yes this is all correct many
thank you he's directing like a hostage
yes yes I agree with a camera with a gun
are you at the puppet and I get to live
okay we did one for the Food Network
called pastry CEO a street CEO I like
cake yeah one for a PLC called nip stick
wars lipstick wars yes
oh they wouldn't let you do that on
today's show I wouldn't let me do it on
the Today Show you a matter that's a
classier very nice they were very
you